so if you're looking for a job
listen up this segment is for you okay
so these days you know everyone's
familiar with it people are quitting
people are getting fired people are
moving their jobs it's a great
resignation it's a great reset it's a
great reshuffle great great great great
great reset reset reshuffle read all
that okay but eventually
you need to land somewhere
you can't just be looking for a job or
job hopping year after year after year
after year that's not a good look yeah
you settle down somewhere yeah okay so
now is the time to obviously make your
moves get a raise get a better job
figure it out it's a great reset
reshuffle this is one of the benefits of
covet is now sort of the employees have
a lot of power these days you say look
i'm getting unemployment you think i'm
going to work to you for less than you
know for unemployment i know there's a
lot of a lot of things are happening
these days so you know who actually had
some very strong feelings on this when i
saw this article i said
let's have this gentleman when do you
familiar with mr wonderful from shark
tank david yes i love mr you love mr
wonderful kevin o'leary he's actually
worth about 400 billion dollars yeah so
when he speaks about what college did he
go to
find that out fiu did he he didn't go to
fius from canada
of toronto or something mcgill okay
find that out while i'm talking so i
guarantee you somewhere in canada all
right university of ontario that's my
guess okay
so he opened up about um
getting a new job these days company how
companies basically operate listen this
guy's
um purchasing companies left and right
he's opening up companies investing
companies uh he knows a thing or two
about well you know what type of
employees can make a company work well
you got an answer for me yeah i got an
answer he received an honors bachelor's
degree in environmental studies and
psychology from the university of
waterloo waterloo canada bro yep and
then you got another thing at the
university of western ontario didn't i
say university of ontario you did
this wasn't the western one i know he's
from canada sauce talks fast they're
really nice people up there in canada so
he says look
you know he's got a lot of financial
advice a lot of money stuff a lot of
investments a lot of stuff he's doing on
shark tank but he says this is the one
red flag that i see this boom antenna
goes up high alert i throw your resume
right into the garbage can i said oh
damn god this guy even give it a second
look he said this is the biggest red
flag on your resume he says he sees this
going straight in the garbage boom
he says the one red front flag above all
is candidates who are bouncing all over
the place that in the last two years
have been at four different jobs he said
that is numero uno uh uh ain't happening
ain't hiring this person red flags all
over this person's resume let me get
into it he says if an act if an
applicant's resume shows them holding
multiple jobs over the past couple years
i simply put that thing right in the
trash he's not even going to look at you
i no no no it's like the fact the fat
girl the ugly girl drunker at the end of
the bar
sorry
i went there
sorry i'm sure you're a great person i
put it right in the trash yeah right in
the trash can
i'm sorry
um
and he goes on to say companies don't
like it because they invest
in
you let's talk about that so if you're
gonna leave them after a few months it's
an absolute total waste of money this is
per kevin o'leary you know there's
onboarding there's training there's
getting you up to speed if you work
remotely they're sending you equipment
all that's he says when you apply to new
job you need to be prepared to invest
your time into that company and then he
says something here which i actually
kind of disagree with i've agreed with
him up until this point up to this point
he says
you need to have a mental commitment
whether you like the job or not
you need to stay there for at least two
years
you have to have a minimum of a 24 month
commitment so hold on
if you don't like the job
because kevin o'leary thinks you should
stay there for two years you need to
stay there i actually disagree with that
i disagree with that if you hate the job
get the hell out of there i agree but
find the job that you want to be at the
goal is to have less jobs on your resume
than more jobs on your resume you know
the last time i've updated my resume 15
years ago because i'm at the same
financial firm for 15 years
when i came to valuetainment they're
like send me a resume i don't need a
resume
whatever
the point is this sometimes less is more
quality jobs over quantity jobs you ever
see that they um someone's resume and
over like the last five years there's
like 15 jobs it's like dude that's
that's not a good look right that
doesn't help you yeah okay
i see these guys just well they might
you guys might need to update your
resume after some of these issues that
we're having today there fellas
um
anyway so highlight the number of
companies the companies you're at for
one to two years not three to six months
even if you're at a great company for
three months don't put on your resume it
didn't work out well gotcha you
understand what i'm saying yeah no
totally because above all you got to
understand something
above all i learned this from biz doc
companies want
loyalty
they want to know that you're not going
anywhere they're not they don't want to
know that you're just looking at them as
a platform to get ahead three six months
a year and then boom move on put it on
the resume they've spent all this time
onboarding you and then you're out the
door companies
want loyalty right so and even if you're
gonna go get a raise so sometimes talk
about the talked about the biz doc if
you're going to go get a raise you need
to convey hey look i don't want to go
anywhere
okay we have to have this conversation
i'm looking for a raise i got to tell
you i've done some research companies in
that do what i do in a certain field are
currently paying x y and z i don't want
to go anywhere
god forbid something happens you get i
get fired or the company goes under
that's my market value i don't want to
go anywhere i want to be here conveying
loyal loyalty
with that being said what can we do
right that's the type of conversation to
to have
regarding
um the loyalty conversation you have to
convey loyalty because basically
basically his point is this
i don't wanna waste my time with you if
you're only to be over three to six
months you're a waste of absolute time
yeah even a year like what exactly and
putting all of this effort into
something exactly you're gonna leave in
a year so do you guys agree with kevin
o'leary do you disagree do you kind of
bop you kind of there's parts of it like
the one part i didn't agree with kevin
lee around is if you hate your job you
still need to stick it out for two years
i don't think so
no yeah if if you absolutely me like
you're miserable and you've tried
everything you've tried going through
the list of being it's been there for
six months and it's yes and it's just
not working out i don't know
then it's like yeah choose your mental
health over because you won't you know
you won't learn anything
but i mean
yeah i totally agree if you're bouncing
back they invest not only that they mess
money into you dude exactly like
training onboarding systems competition
benefits get all that and then you're
out the door yeah so i totally
understand where he's coming from but
obviously if it doesn't work out
um and you're not happy you kind of got
to keep it moving but anyway i think
this is actually a great advice from
kevin o'leary
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken